hi there steve kaufman here
today i'm going to talk about vocabulary
words
the most important thing in language
learning remember if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe
click on the bell to get notifications
the reason i'm talking about this is
that i saw in a discussion the other day
on
uh
language learning someone said you know
there are
uh
what does it mean to know a word there
are all these different stages of
knowing a word and there is a great
analysis of knowing
you know the
grammar of the word which word it's used
with the different meanings of the word
the scope of meaning of the word
whether you can just recognize it in
context
and to me all of that is not important
i think there is far too much analysis
yes there is a continuum the first time
we see a word we
don't know what it means of course or we
may guess at it or we're probably better
not to guess by the way better to look
it up has been my experience
but uh we get a sense of what the word
might mean in a certain context
and gradually we see the word in other
contexts and we have a sense of the
scope of meaning of that word
maybe
the word only has one obvious meaning
like you know
wood wood can only be wood
w-o-o-d
uh but wooden can mean that someone is
not very responsive or emotional so
there can be you know
shades of meaning of these different
words but these are all things that we
gradually acquire and there's no
particular benefit in analyzing these
different ways in which we know a word
in my opinion
uh for example at link
i think one of the very useful things at
link is that we count
words we count the words that you have
read we count the number of words or
phrases that you have saved we tell you
how many words you don't know
because you haven't seen them before at
link and from that we develop a lot of
statistics
which are motivating we have milestones
of your achievements or you can judge
the difficulty of a certain text by how
many unknown words there are there i
personally find 10 to 15 percent
um unknown words is kind of ideal
because i'm learning enough new words
but i'm not having to look up every
second or third word but this will be
you know it'll vary from person to
person
so but we don't worry like people say
well you know you can't claim to know 15
000 words because at link we count each
form of the word as a different word
yeah it's easier for the computer to
measure that the computer has a tougher
time working out if this word is part of
a word family or not you know
activity active action are they part of
the same family whatever i don't know
so
words i think it's best to simplify to
have a gordian knot
approach the guardian knot of course was
alexander was asked to untie this
nod he just cut it with a sword
simplify the number of words that you
can recognize passively in a given
context
good enough for link it's good enough uh
you may find the next time you see it
you don't know what it means because we
forget so much we forget so much
forgetting is such a big part of
language learning forgetting and
relearning forgetting and relearning is
is such an important part and because
therefore the process is kind of like a
fuzzy process where we are gradually
absorbing the language and the brain is
starting to connect certain things and
forgets us
to forget certain things and as long as
we are motivated and keep going we will
acquire more and more of the language
now
i decided to do a little bit of research
for today's video by the way you'll
notice that my thumb is okay some people
expressed you know the wish that my
thumb get better and all it is is that
uh with the winter weather and i do all
the dishwashing and i really should wear
gloves
but then i start getting these little uh
you know chaps or or whatever you want
to call it
splits in my thumb and so i put a little
bit of cream there a little bit of you
know
saran wrap and
bandage it and that way it gets better
uh now so i went to my uh bookshelf now
i have a lot of books on a variety of
subjects i like history i like politics
i like a lot of different things but
also on language so i just went and got
the books that i have
here that deal with words vocabulary and
language teaching second language
vocabulary acquisition
vocabulary description acquisition and
pedagogy
the online educator that's a little
different second language acquisition
rod ellis
language teaching methodology how
languages are learned
whatever i have a lot of books i've read
them i think they're overly complicated
i think that all of that the gordian
solution is stephen krashen so here is
one book that i got when i was in taiwan
attending a language conference where he
was speaking it's called explorations in
language acquisition and use the taipei
lectures
very inexpensive and
tremendous value and it cuts through all
the unnecessary
uh stuff
learning vocabulary in another language
and i could go through them and
i mean it doesn't really matter any page
you open designing and using a
simplified reading scheme for vocabulary
development making decisions using
labeled diagrams vocabulary in
discourse reading and sentence
completion it's a whole bunch of stuff
that just complicates everything just
keep enjoying the language then they
have these also on the subject of how to
accumulate words you have these like
toefl so they have a bunch of words and
and uh you know essential toefl
vocabulary you'll work very hard to
learn the word treasury or
preconception or or whatever in the hope
that that word will show up on your
toefl test but the reality is
that word frequency
declines so quickly that a lot of those
low frequency words that you'll go to
all that trouble to try and learn you're
going to forget them and chances are
they won't show up
on the toefl exam so you're better off
to simply spend your time enjoying the
language
reading and listening as much as you can
to acquire the language naturally and in
that natural way eventually words will
stick and words can stick quite
quickly it all depends really i'm just
going to check my time here you know it
all depends
and how similar the language is to a
language you already know so
uh i uh did a video where i was doing
czech and with my knowledge of russian i
accumulated words very quickly
uh
you know if you know spanish and you do
portuguese you're accumulating you're
going to accumulate words very quickly
on the other hand learning arabic or
persian
not so fast and in fact the biggest help
is
arabic words in persian or persian words
in turkish and so it depends what
language you know
uh if you're dealing with a language
that has very few common you know bits
of vocabulary it's going to take you
quite a while but the process is still
the same it's not doing these toefl
books it's not doing special oh and i
should i was going to read you something
too i googled uh what does it mean to
know a word
and so you get this tremendously
complicated you know understanding it's
basic meaning denotation connotation
understanding the grammatical form
understanding that words may have more
than one meaning we know that from every
language understanding what variety of
english the word belongs to the word
doesn't belong to any variety okay
just by
dent of reading or listening to
english around a certain context you're
going to learn that vocabulary
so
knowing how it relates to other work
words in lexical
sets
hipponomy mironomy synonymy anthony i
mean all of this stuff is tremendously
complicated it keeps the language
teachers busy but it has very little to
do with learning
learning is very simple learning words
and learning words fast if you want to
learn fast
then
choose a language which has a lot of
words in common with a language you
already know
otherwise be resigned to the fact that
it's going to take as long as it takes
and as long as you are enjoying
what you are doing as long as you are
enjoying the language
as long as you have done the things that
i referred to in my
video on on having a language plan and
you've got content surrounding you that
meets your needs and meets your
interests and is at your level and you
keep at it the words are eventually
gonna stick and that's all you can
really do
and uh you know to finish off i would
direct you to two videos that i did on
the subject of vocabulary acquisition
and the importance of words to reinforce
what i've been talking about today so
there you go thank you for listening bye
for now